the question many Americans are asking
why are there so many of these mass
shootings and what can be done to
prevent them of course when a Doug
mackelway reports tonight the debate
goes beyond guns to the actual fabric of
American culture as Kentucky governor
Matt Bevins said during a White House
visit earlier this week this culture of
death is becoming pervasive and if it's
not addressed by all the imperfect
people in this room with a sense of
purpose in a sense of aspiration I think
we're gonna see a continued trajectory
that's not good most humans cannot
fathom the depths of depravity that
would allow a young man to shoot up a
school filled with children violent
crime rates have been declining not so
mass shootings a confluence of factors
may be contributed academic in some
sense of nihilistic hopelessness among
not just young men young people in
general the cultural revolution of the
1960s brought welcome change to
discrimination against minorities women
and gays but many contend the revolution
has not gone far enough
toxic masculinity is the man's fear that
he's losing his power and because
minorities and women are taking higher
positions and they have more power that
white men and men in general are afraid
that they're going to lose their
strength critics argue the revolution
throughout deeply embedded traditions of
culture and child-rearing it's almost
impossible to express how much more
important it is to be a mother or a
parent who guides the the rearing and
the development of a child than it is to
be a mere research scientist Goethe is
one of the world's foremost research
scientists he's also blood about his
belief that the sixties revolution
replaced rigorous scholarship with a
dumbed-down curricula hurting even Ivy
League students they don't know anything
we've given ourselves a path in
educating them in rearing them as a
result of the Cultural Revolution
observers say schools have to manage
more than they can handle
they're called upon to act as parents to
those children whose parents aren't
acting like parents they're called upon
to be psychologists and judicial agents
and all
these things and they simply can't do it
both Peterson and Lerner believe gun
control and mental health debates can
wait a higher priority is to fix the
culture and broken boys with time-tested
ideals of masculine role models
responsibility and sacrifice they need
to have at least one person in their
life one straight-arrow that truck that
flies true to orient themselves properly
and if they don't have that they can be
easily lost that thought may be
resonating Peterson's new book twelve
rules for life an antidote to chaos
rocketed to number one on Amazon on
January 16th it's very first day of
release and has remained in the top two
spots ever since Brett Doug thank you